[Applause]
when i say jump you say how high
okay let's put this to the ultimate test
by hopping around the solar system
literally
what differences in gravity would you
experience
on which planet could you jump as high
as a house
and on which planets would jumping lead
to your demise
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you jumped on every planet in
the solar system
every object with mass is subject to
gravity
this includes you of course
whether you're standing on your two feet
or lounging on the sofa the earth's
gravity is pulling you toward the center
of the planet
when you jump the force of your muscles
allows you to overcome that gravity and
accelerate upward
once you're in the air gravity slows you
down and eventually your velocity hits
zero and you fall back to the surface
the planets in our solar system come in
all sizes so the force of their gravity
differs too
your mass would stay exactly the same
but from one planet to the next your
weight would be very different
so could you bound gracefully over
mountains on one while on another you'd
barely be able to lift a toe
before you go on this interplanetary
journey in our solar system there's one
place you might want to stop here on
earth
the place where the future is already
here
the museum of the future is a new global
scientific landmark provided by dubai
and the uae to the world
it shows the amazing new technologies
waiting for humanity in the following
decades i mean look at this the museum
of the future is an architectural
masterpiece and inside it has five main
levels from innovation laboratories with
augmented reality and human machine
interaction to humanity's next home in
space
here you can experience the future today
i would totally geek out on level 5 and
check out what life could be like aboard
a huge space station
if you like space and exploration you
should head there too
you know you need some practical
knowledge of the future before you go
jumping on different planets in the
solar system
your interplanetary jumping experiment
would begin right here on earth
okay not the most exciting place to
start but a good place of comparison
if you're close to the average jumper
you should be able to squat swing your
arms and leap about half a meter high
all in about one second
but don't let me underestimate you
if you're an extremely talented athlete
like javier sotomayor you could set a
new world record by jumping over
2.45 meters
whoa not too shabby
making a quick first stop on the moon
you'd find gravity six times weaker than
it is on earth well that's because the
moon has about 80 times less mass
here you'd only need to jump at a
velocity of two kilometers per second to
lift off the surface
and with your average jumping velocity
you should be able to jump about three
meters high
meanwhile earth's most talented jumper
would be able to bound over an entire
house
okay moving on to the rocky surface of
the planet closest to the sun mercury
with a spectacular close-up view and
temperatures hitting
430 degrees
you'd be drenched in sweat already
mercury is smaller than earth the
gravitational pull is about one-third of
what you're accustomed to here at home
so despite exhausting conditions
you'd be able to jump about three times
as high
okay let's get out of the frying pan and
into the fire by taking a leap on an
even hotter planet venus
very similar in size to earth this
planet has a surface gravity about 91
percent of earth's
here you'd be able to jump ever so
slightly higher than you could back home
but you definitely wouldn't want to hang
out for too long in this thick scorching
hot atmosphere
so time to cool off on mars
you better keep your leg muscles warm
though the average temperature on the
red planet is minus 62 degrees
but the good news you'd feel lighter
mars has about 10 times less mass than
earth and for this reason you'd be able
to jump to nearly the exact same height
as you did back on mercury
okay now leaving the rocky planets
behind it would be time to test your
skills on a gas giant like jupiter
this planet is so large that all the
other planets of the solar system could
fit inside it
jupiter has very intense gravity so
you'd be feeling a lot heavier than you
do right now
if you tried to jump here you'd only be
able to get a pathetic 20 centimeters
off the ground
now if it helps your ego this scenario
would be impossible for a simple reason
it's because the gas giants have no
surface to jump from so you'd have to
stay on top of your spaceship and if i
can offer some advice
don't fall off
on saturn you'd be surprised to find
that you can jump only about three
centimeters less than you could on earth
despite the planet having 95 times the
mass
saturn's surface gravity is quite
similar to our home planet
okay now heading toward the dark cold
edges of the solar system you'd take
your leaps on uranus and neptune
just be sure to avoid slipping on these
ice giants
on uranus you'd find a relatively
familiar gravitational pull
because of this you'd be able to jump
about 6 centimeters higher than you
could on earth
then finally you'd reach the bleak foggy
surface of neptune and despite your
aching muscles you'd power through for
one last jump
and that could be tough considering the
severe winds that dwarf even the largest
hurricanes back on earth
but you'd take your best shot and
struggling against the slightly stronger
gravity
you'd reach 44 centimeters
roughly the same as back home
speaking of back home i think it's time
to head back
okay you'd make it home exhausted
too bad all the planets were closer
together
like stuffed into the habitable zone
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you